>>Rich Hyndman: Hi there.
Welcome to this talk on Google Play Services.
My name is Richard Hyndman.
I head up Android developer relations across
Europe.
>>Reto Meier: And I'm Reto Meier, the Android
developer operations tech lead.
>>Rich Hyndman: Excellent.
And together we are clearly the Android developer
relations football team.
We'll take on any other developer relations
team if they want it.
>>Reto Meier: That is a challenge.
>>Rich Hyndman: Let's start with what is Google
Play Services, a little bit of background
to this.
Google Play Services is a single library that
brings together all the APIs for Google services
and play services into a single place on Android
devices, Android devices version 2.2 and above.
This means that you can implement your applications
and we can implement our applications without
having to worry about device support.
This is the fifth major release we've done
of Google Play Services and we've become exceedingly
efficient at it.
If you hadn't all been on the same Wi-Fi network
over the last 24 hours I would be sure that
you've all got it on your devices already.
Maybe conference situations change that a
little bit.
So Google Play Services is covering Google+,
Google+ sign-in, maps.
Hopefully you have used it already.
And OAuth.
What I mean by authentication is that Google
Play Services provides a single authorization
API for you to get access to all of our services
through the library.
You and your users have a consistent way to
receive OAuth access tokens for Google services,
but even more than that Google Play Services
is such a core part of our platform for the
Google ecosystem that we need to make sure
it's always up to date.
We need to make sure that we can do bug fixes
and updates outside of the Android framework
releases and outside of the carrier release
schedule.
So of course, it's updated through the Play
Store.
Why is it on Android 2.2 and above?
Android 2.2 and above is now 98.2 and growing
percentage of the active Android users that
hit the Play Store.
Also FroYo added some really handy API, things
like saving applications to mass storage,
and these are the things that most applications
that use play services are probably going
to be using.
A few people have asked why we have both play
services and the Android support library.
>>Reto Meier: I have been wondering.
>>Rich Hyndman: You will know that it's in
the name.
Really Google Play Services is, of course,
supporting our play ecosystem, making sure
you can use the APIs.
The Android support library is an open source
library for the Android ecosystem and for
you the developers to include in your applications
in the source and you can use it on all your
devices that you would like to.
So this talk is called what's new in Google
Play Services, so let's get into some of the
meat of it.
Mr. Meier.
>>Reto Meier: So you heard a lot about things
related to Google Play Services during the
keynote yesterday and there are deep dive
presentations for pretty much everything in
Google Play Services, both the things which
we have just released and the things that
have been around for a little while.
So the thing here is not to dive too deeply
into an individual thing, but to give you
a bit of an overview into the things you may
be interested in seeing, particularly if you
haven't had a chance to go into all the other
Google Play Services sessions so far at I/O.
So let's look at some of the exciting new
features that we've just released here at
I/O 2013.
And I think the one that is the most interesting
and exciting for me is location-based services.
So in addition to the maps fragments and the
maps V2 stuff that we added traditional previously
we now have the ability to detect location
within Google Play Services.
And there's a reason we brought this in here.
We're now able to do much cleverer things.
We have a new fused location provider which
does all of the hard work for you.
So if you've ever used location in your Android,
and I'm sure most of you have, you know that
doing so in a way that's efficient while still
allowing you to get the best location results
can be quite tedious.
There's a lot of code you have to write in
order to be able to use those best practices.
So what the location team have done is taken
all of that hard work, they've put it all
behind the scenes, behind this fused location
provider, and it will do all of that stuff
for you.
It will detect which providers are available,
it will figure out when things are turned
on, when things are turned off, which providers
are providing the best result at a time particular
time.
All of that hard work is done for you.
And to use it is actually nice and easy.
Like most of the Google Play Services clients,
you simply have to create the instance first,
call connect and it will asynchronously bind
your service or application to the Google
Play Services service.
Once that's happened you're able to treat
that location client in exactly the same way
you used to handle the old location-based
services client.
And this looks a lot like the naive approach
that we used to do back in the olden days,
last week.
We had to specify what our interval was and
we had to say what provider we wanted to use
to get the location updates.
And in most cases we were usually using multiple
providers or letting the system determine
which provider we wanted, but then you have
this problem because GPS is always the best,
right?
It's always the most accurate location.
Well, it is when you're outside, but less
so when you're inside, so now you're having
to keep track of all the different providers
and figure out which is the most appropriate
for your current location.
Fused location provider does all of that work
for you.
You just give us an interval, it can be a
minimum interval or a maximum interval, and
then tell us what your priority is.
What's more important?
Do you want to get the most accurate results
that you can or do you want to make sure that
the battery lasts as long as possible or do
you want to leave it up to us and ask fused
location provider to try and find the right
balance for you?
Because no matter what you choose, we're always
going to try to get the most accurate result
with the least battery.
This is just our way of knowing which way
to push it, in which direction.
So that's one of the big advantages in fused
location provider.
And the other thing is we have the logic behind
that at any time as part of Google Play Services
and we can push that on our users' devices
without you having to do anything.
You don't have to recompile code, you simply
set the things once and we will continue to
try to make the results more accurate and
more efficient with each release.
Not satisfied with just improving all of our
location-based apps, the location team have
also created a new geofencing API.
This works a lot like we expected the old
proximity alerts to work, but this actually
works.
So it will keep track of all the geofences
from every application and figure out which
of our providers we should be using based
on how far away we are from the boundaries
around each of those geofences.
So we create those boundaries simply by specifying
a particular location and a radius around
it and whether we're interested in users who
move into or out of or both of that boundary
condition.
And so because this is all handled by the
central fused location provider, all of the
geofences from every app are known to us and
so we can figure out what should we be using.
Should we stick with GPS, should we go back
to cell ID because we're far enough?
Because we know how far we are from the boundaries.
This means you get to take advantage of all
this contextual information around location
without having to follow the user every step
of the way, without the complex analysis to
figure out whether you want to turn on GPS
or turn on cell or Wi-Fi triangulation or
any other technology that is made available.
We do all of that hard work for you and want
to be sure you are notified whenever it is
relevant.
Now, because the location team are overachievers,
never really satisfied with just making things
better and making things work, they've decided
that they want to introduce something completely
new.
And so now we have activity recognition.
So now not only can we tell where a user is,
but we can tell what they're actually doing.
So we know whether they're standing still,
whether they're running, whether they're cycling,
whether they're driving.
And now you can use this information either
to create entire new categories of apps.
You could have an app, say a fitness app,
and rather than having to say what activity
you're doing, the activity detection can tell
you.
Activity recognition can figure out exactly
what they're doing and fill in those details.
So you can use it that way, and this is how
you request those activity updates.
You simply set what interval you're interested
in and then specify pending intent that is
going to get triggered whenever the activity
changes.
So now we can be clever about this.
We can say, okay, maybe we're just interested
in all the changes so we can track that and
do something useful or maybe we can make our
apps more efficient.
We can provide a different user experience
based on what their current activity is.
So maybe it's looking for points of interest
nearby.
If we're standing still, we're not moving,
the buildings aren't moving, then we can pause,
we can disable those updates.
If we're in the car we want to get the updates
as quickly as possible so the passenger can
figure out a good place to eat.
Or maybe you can flip it around.
Maybe it's sports scores or news, you're standing
still, and that's when you want the most frequent
updates.
And when you're cycling, the phone is in your
pocket, you may as well disable those updates
because if you're not in a position to look
at your phone there's no point in firing up
the cell radio in order to get those downloads.
So it's really a way that you can utilize
this information to create entirely new apps
or more efficient apps.
It is a brand new API, so it's a really great
opportunity to think outside the box, to figure
out how can you use this new sensor information
to create a better experience, more efficient
experience for your users.
Now, I'm not going to go into any more detail
here.
Like I said, we want to cover everything pretty
quickly.
The good news is that Waleed and Jaikumar
have already presented all of this information
and if we had a time travel API built into
Android and Google Play Services you could
go back in time and watch it live earlier
today.
Unfortunately that's not going to be possible.
>>Rich Hyndman: But they released that back
in time, time travel delay.
>>Reto Meier: No.
>>Rich Hyndman: It's not far.
It's only 11:15.
>>Reto Meier: We'll talk about this later.
>>Rich Hyndman: Secret stuff.
>>Reto Meier: So check it out on YouTube.
It's close enough.
You can rewind time effectively and see all
the information.
They dig much deeper into the details of how
this is done, what you can do to really take
advantage of all of these APIs within your
applications.
Anything else that you want to talk about
today, Rich?
>>Rich Hyndman: Sure.
Of course we have something else.
We have the thing that I'm most impressed
with in the latest set of Google Play Services
is Google Play games.
Everything is better when it's competitive,
right?
Hopefully some of you have already been playing
the new Google Play games.
You've seen the enormous leaderboard outside.
Is anyone on the leaderboard?
No?
One or two people at the back.
That's good stuff.
>>Reto Meier: They're just shy.
>>Rich Hyndman: So the things we're talking
about with Google Play games, achievements,
leaderboards, cloud save and real-time multiplayer
invitations.
Because what is multiplayer without invitations?
>>Reto Meier: It's a game by yourself.
>>Rich Hyndman: It's not multiplayer.
So you may know how all this performs, but
do you manage all of this great new stuff?
Inside the new Google developer console you
will get a little tab in the top left corner,
the little play games logo, and you can tap
on that and then from inside the new layouts
you will see the ability to add in your leaderboards,
your achievements and things like that straight
into the play developer console across platforms
that supports iOS and Web.
Not only that, but if you have a look in the
Play Store now at Beach Buggy Blitz, if you
scroll down you will see it supports leaderboards
and achievements.
I don't think that one is multiplayer.
But users are going to know which of the play
services you've integrated into your application
before they install it.
Just adding a bit more compelling.
So inside the actual game we provide you with
default look and feel for achievements.
You can see the little dialogue that appears,
and the entire achievement screen.
So you can just drop this in straight away
if you want.
Drop it in, it will work fine for you.
Or you can get access to the raw data and
integrate it as you previously would, make
it look and feel like your application.
The same applies to leaderboards.
Again, there's a default look and feel for
the leaderboards, if you want, and users will
recognize it and understand that it's Google
play games or you can get access to the leaderboards,
and Hugo hopefully won't be at the top.
So now you have leaderboards, you have achievements
that are going to follow you around from device
to device.
So it only makes sense if with those achievements
you're following your game state with you.
What you really need is some sort of Cloud
Save service.
>>> What would you call something like that?
>>Rich Hyndman: I don't know.
We call ours the Cloud Save service.
So with Cloud Save you now have four 128K
blocks of data that you can store the user's
data in for that application.
Unfortunately this huge chunk of data doesn't
come out of their drive space.
>>Reto Meier: That's lucky.
It's almost half a meg per game.
It's a lot.
>>Rich Hyndman: So you get this chunk of data
that doesn't come out of the drive space,
you synchronize the state maybe for the four
chunks.
You could have one chunk for avatar, another
chunk for their profile information, game
progress, things like that, store them and
synchronize them.
Cloud Save also comes with conflict resolution
strategies as well.
If you want to find out more about that, again,
go back to yesterday this time.
We certainly haven't released that API.
And watch new developments in mobile gaming.
>>Reto Meier: That seems like a really simple
title.
>>Rich Hyndman: Who would actually call it
new developments in mobile gaming if you had
to go something to hide?
It was called an introduction to play games
services.
So in the future when this comes out on YouTube,
look for introduction to play games services
and you will find out more details about all
of that.
Maybe unsurprisingly this is all backed by
Google+ so you add the Google+ sign into your
application and then you get access to all
these fantastic play services.
For even more details there's another one.
There's a lot of play games to what's going
on.
>>Reto Meier: There were a few.
>>Rich Hyndman: Advanced games development
topics, which sounds like a cloaked talk title,
but I didn't go and check.
So now we've backed up all our data up.
Let's restore Reto's former position and see
what's next.
>>Reto Meier: So one of the other really exciting
new parts of Google Play Services, most of
the ones I'm talking about today, actually
existed in the world before Google Play Services,
but have recently been brought into the fold.
And that is certainly the case for Google
Cloud Messaging.
This is already an API, which hopefully many
of you are very familiar with, to help make
your travel transfers that much more efficient.
We've pulled that into Google Play Services
and as part of the introduction process we
forced the team to build some new APIs as
well.
So hopefully you're all very familiar with
the basics behind Google Cloud Messaging,
and that's the fact that you can have your
server update your client to tell it when
it needs to do a refresh.
So in the bad old days we used to set repeating
alarms and at best maybe they were inexact
repeating alarms, but either way you were
still waking up the device, turning on the
radio, pinging a server just to say, hey,
is there anything I need to download?
And most of the times the answer was no.
And even if the answer is yes, it was like,
yeah, two hours ago would have been useful.
So what Google Cloud Messaging lets you do
is have the server notify each of your clients
when it's time, when there is new data, so
you can reduce the amount of radio traffic,
reduce the amount of battery use associated
with those transfers by only making them happen
when you know there is data to transfer.
Now, one of the exciting new things that we've
added is the ability to go the other way around.
So as you heard in the keynote yesterday we
can now have a system where you can create
a persistent XMPP connection with your server
and the Google Cloud Messaging server.
This gives you now the ability to send messages
from your device back to your server over
this connection without you having to maintain
that consistent connection using something
like a hanging GAC or something equivalent
to that.
We'll do it once and we do it in a way that
we know is going to work across carriers and
be as efficient as possible and give you the
ability to have the low latency, that high
reliability connection to send data backwards
and forwards without having you to do yourself,
using infrastructure that we use for all of
our services.
And you can take it a step further as well.
So you can use this same technology to now
send messages from one -- from your app running
on one device to the same app running on other
devices.
So if you have things like a notification
and it pops up someone's phone and they swipe
it to dismiss or snooze it, but that same
notification is now going to be transmitted
to all of your other phones.
So what this API lets you do is basically
send that message to say the user has handled
it, it has been actioned, you can remove it.
This is really nice.
This is a great way of demonstrating to people
that your app is aware of the ecosystem, it
knows it has more than one phone.
It's not just an app that runs on all of these
devices.
It's built around them.
It understands who they are and what their
needs are.
So by doing that it just works the way that
people expect it should.
I've already dismissed this notification,
it shouldn't appear anywhere else.
Implementation from the client side is really
straightforward.
You get a new Google Cloud Messaging client,
you call send, you specify their project ID
if you want to talk directly to the server
or a notification ID if you want to transmit
this to other devices.
Server side is a little bit more complicated,
not really my wheelhouse, so I'm going to
leave that to Francesco, who is in this room
I think directly after us, to give us all
the details and exactly how you can use both
these new APIs and all of the previous Google
Cloud Messaging APIs as part of Google Play
Services.
Would you like to talk about the next one,
Rich?
>>Rich Hyndman: Sure.
We like to write services that are simple
to movement and get out of the way of the
flow for users.
They just make everything more simple across
the board.
Google Wallet have announced here at I/O that
they have launched Google Wallet instant buy.
There are some restrictions on it.
You need to be a whitelisted user.
(Indiscernible) for now.
You can to talk to the guys downstairs at
the wallet stand if you want to register for
it.
The flow that this gives you is that you can
now sell physical goods inside your Android
applications using the Gmail account on the
device and the Google Wallet on the device.
So as you're selling your goods, they will
upload and there will be an instant buy with
the Google Wallet button inside the app and
they can just tap that, there's no credit
card details needed, there's no log-in needed.
Everything is just a single straightforward
flow, it gets charged through the wallet on
the device and you can ship the goods to the
address that that provides you with.
So thanks to the Google Wallet team for that.
There was a talk on that yesterday, what's
new on mobile payments on Android.
If you're watching this in the future you
may be able to grab that straight away.
>>Reto Meier: Great.
So that all sounds pretty good.
How can I get this?
How can I use it?
The whole in play services comes through the
SDK manager.
Hopefully you all know where the Android SDK
measuring is already.
Nods in the room.
So it's under the window menu in Eclipse and
the tools menu in the new Android Studio or
IntelliJ.
You pull that up and scroll right down to
the bottom, and there will be an item down
there for Google Play services.
Once you install that, it will install the
Google Play services package into the URL
that's above my head somewhere, extras.Google.GooglePlayServices.
And so if you have it installed, you can go
and check it out there, and inside there there's
the samples for it, you've got some documentation
and you've got the client library as well.
One of the samples is called Panorama, because
one of the Google Play services is Panorama,
which enables you to load up panoramas and
photo spheres you've taken with your Android
devices and display them inside your application.
So using the panorama sample, I'm going to
go through quickly how you would use Google
Play services inside Android Studio and inside
Eclipse.
In Android Studio you're going to go for create
project from existing sources.
You're going to run through and find that
extras Google Play services directory on your
machine and you're going to import the panorama
sample.
We recommend that you also copy the play services
library into your work space so when Play
services is updating to different versions
through the SDK manager, it doesn't change
the one that you are using.
Multiple projects will be running off it.
That's a recommendation for Eclipse and IntelliJ
users.
So then in IntelliJ, or Android Studio, you're
going to have to create this module, and because
Google Play services includes resources as
well as class files, the resources are kept
in the project and the class files are kept
in the jar file.
So you need to import the module as a project,
first of all, for Play services, and then
also import the jar file as a library and
create dependencies on both of those.
If you miss out one of these steps, unfortunately
you're going to get like maps will be in red
in Android Studio because it can't find the
classes because you didn't import the jar
file.
This is going to be much easier in the future
as we're going to have a maven artifact for
Play service, so with the Gradle build system,
it will do the dependency management for you.
Eclipse, very similar flow.
You're going to through, you're going to copy
Play services library into your work space,
you're going to import that.
Also import the panorama sample.
In Eclipse you just need to make the one dependency.
You make the dependency from panorama sample
onto the library, and Eclipse figures out
there's also a jar file in there and it imports
that for you.
So it should look like this one in Eclipse.
Of course some of our services like Maps use
APIs and API keys as well, and Reto is going
to tell you how to get hold of an API key.
>>Reto Meier: Thanks, Rich.
So the way this works is that you need to
start by going to the API console, and you
can find that at code.google.com/apis/console,
which is tricky for a lot of us to remember
because my default is always to go to developer.android.com.
But nonetheless, if you go there, you can
go into the services where you'll see a long
list of APIs, and you simply choose the ones
you want to utilize, and turn it on.
So it's actually pretty straightforward.
Of course if we just gave you an API key which
you could cut and paste and start putting
into your applications, it would be really
easy for nefarious characters like this one
or this guy to steal your API key and start
using your quota.
It would make it hard for you to track what
your app is doing.
If there are quota restrictions, they could
easily start eating all of yours.
So to mitigate against that, we make sure
that all the keys that we have are linked
to a particular certificate and particular
package name so that only you can use your
API key.
And that way you can get full control over
the list of apps and certificates you want
in the API access part of the console.
Now, once you've gone through that process,
that is going to give you an API key.
This, because it's signed or at least it's
associated specifically with your certificate
and your package name is unique, you can put
it into with your manifest as shown here and
all of your Google Play services will start
working.
>>Rich Hyndman: Okay.
Something on auth.
No matter how many times I go through this,
auth and auth is always confusion.
Authentication and authorization shouldn't
have been called the same thing because it's
just annoying, or at least start with the
same name.
Authentication is securely identifying the
party, so those Google accounts on your device
are authenticated.
Authorization is getting access to services
for that identified party, for the authenticated
party.
Google Play services is offering standardized
authorization for the authenticated account,
not just for products that are inside Google
Play services but also for Google APIs on
the Web as well.
Previously, the flow for getting authorization
tokens for Google APIs was a bit of a pain,
involved web views and some other things,
some people wrote some nice libraries for
it but hey, there you go.
Now with Google Play services you can get
hold of these tokens much more easily.
So it starts off with choosing an account.
You want the user to choose the account you
are going to use to authorize to get into
the services and that's just one line of code.
You use the account picker filter on Google
services and Google accounts and it shows
a dialogue to the user, which you have probably
seen before, where they can choose one of
their Gmail accounts.
Just one line of code.
Then before you go ahead and use Google Play
services, you just want to check that it's
there, that it's on the device, that it's
the right version and that it's not disabled
because people could do that if they really
felt like it was necessary for some reason.
And then again, that's just one line of code.
Google Play services util, is Google Play
services available.
That can come back with some error codes,
maybe, in these rare cases.
If it does, we have a handy get error dialogue
you can call, and that will show a localized
error dialogue up to the user and hopefully
they can resolve the issue from there.
So now you've got Google Play services is
definitely on the device and working.
You've got your authenticated Gmail account
or Google apps account that you are going
to use to log into the service.
So now you need the access token for that
service.
Again, one line of code again.
The Google auth YouTube get token.
You're parsing in the Gmail account that came
back, and you're going to chain together the
scopes of the services that you want to get
access to.
In this case we're looking at the plus profile
and the YouTube read only scopes, but you
could chain multiple different scopes for
Google services and Google Play services that
you wanted to get access to in this authorization.
When you do this, the user will get another
handy little dialogue saying this application
wants to access YouTube and your plus profile,
and they can click through there and see more
details of exactly what that means.
I'm going to hit okay, with any luck, and
you'll get access to the data.
If it's Google Play services data, you're
just using the token with the library.
If it's one of our Web APIs, you're going
to get that authorization token, put it on
the end of a URL and get access to one of
our APIs.
Anything else from you, Mr. Meier?
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, I think there's one more
thing we wanted to add.
We could +1 it, if you will.
Painful puns are our specialty.
>>Rich Hyndman: Add one more thing to the
deck.
We should have rehearsed this.
This could have been better.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, probably not.
So the thing is you can +1 anything which
has a distinct URL, you can +1 it.
So that means you can have a +1 button to
+1 your app in your app, which isn't a bad
idea, but it's kind of a simple approach.
If you've got content within your application
and it's anything which has a URL to be able
to go to anywhere else, you can have a +1
button for that as well.
So whether that's a news article, a recipe,
a TV show, anything which is within your app
and has that URL, you are also able to add
a +1 button to it.
>>Rich Hyndman: Excellent.
>>Reto Meier: I think we've probably convinced
people that there's enough stuff here to start
playing around with.
Is there a way -- how would they go about
testing this, make sure it actually works.
>>Rich Hyndman: Testing Google Play services.
This is a question we get quite a lot on Google+.
>>Reto Meier: It is a lot.
>>Rich Hyndman: It's a painful question because
when you're testing Google Play services you
can go and buy a device.
You can go and buy a Android 2.2 and above
device.
Nexus devices are great.
Low cost of entry.
If you want to test Google Play services,
you want Android 2.2 and above and of course
the Play Store on it, and you'll be able to
test your Google Play services on it.
>>Reto Meier: I don't know, Rich.
That doesn't sound like a good enough answer
to me.
We can't expect everyone to go out and buy
a device just to test things.
>>Rich Hyndman: Really?
I don't have much a better answer.
No; actually, I said you can test on a device,
because we do have one other thing.
Finally -- da-da-da-da.
>>Reto Meier: I haven't seen this.
What's coming?
>>Rich Hyndman: We have a Google Play services
emulator as well, finally, so you can finally
--
[ Applause ]
>>Rich Hyndman: Wow!
Okay.
It's based on the Google APIs emulator.
We will be updating it with every major release
of Play services going forward, so even if
you do have a device, you can use emulator
to test some of the other form factors, but
it means you don't actually have to have a
device.
And you can use the GPO emulation on that
and the other features.
>>Reto Meier: So any of you who are using
emulators for any kind of testing, particularly
if you are doing things with like multi-device
testing, this is a great way to be able to
do that.
We particularly put it at the end just so
those of you who waited for the full length
of the session would get that to have a sneak
--
>>Rich Hyndman:
You went through to pain to get that one thing.
So you requirements are you have the Google
-- you have the real emulator installed, you
have the Google APIs installed, and you have
the Play services installed, which hopefully
you would have anyway if you are developing
for Play services.
>>Reto Meier: Great.
>>Rich Hyndman: Makes sense.
That's all we've got for this talk.
Thank you all very much.
If you have questions, we have microphones
dotted around and you can talk about Google
Play services.
We also have Jeff over here from the Play
services team, so if you have any technical
questions we're clearly not going to be able
to answer, Jeff can stand up and save the
day for us.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Rich Hyndman: Someone coming to the microphone.
>>> Hi there.
Is the play services emulator, do you have
an X86 image for that or only ARM?
>>Rich Hyndman: It hasn't been launched yet.
Right now I have only seen an ARM one.
>>> You've only seen an ARM?
>>Rich Hyndman: I've only seen an ARM one,
personally, but you never know.
Jeff?
No.
You can talk to Xav and Tor on the tools team
about the emulators.
They're launching that.
>>Reto Meier: We should check in with any
extended people.
Hi, please.
>>> Are you planning on releasing the WebView
as Google Play services so that it can be
updated across different versions of the OS?
>>Reto Meier: That's a good question.
Certainly not anything we've done at this
point.
I'm not sure if there are any future plans.
As usual with anything Google, we can't speak
about future plans, but it's not anything
that I am currently aware of.
>>Rich Hyndman: The great thing for me is
finally being able to test apps with the new
MapFragment.
The v2 MapFragment inside the emulator whilst
you're developing is just really handy.
And this Panorama example as well.
I just checked, we don't have any live questions
off the moderator, so we can carry on.
>>> Hi.
This is awesome, but how is the Play Store
upgrade rate and upgrade velocity?
Is there any plan on there to ensure users
always get the latest version?
>>Reto Meier: So the question is the frequency
with which or the rate at which we update
Google Play services on devices.
It's very, very, very fast.
So we usually -- it usually -- I think we
push it out to everyone within about a week,
I think, and that's conservatively speaking.
So whenever there's a new Google Play services
update, we push that out to all devices very
quickly.
So as long as Google Play is installed, they
will get that update almost instantly.
>>Rich Hyndman: For regular viewers of the
tech press, you might have noticed we started
releasing this version at the start of the
week.
Yes, sir.
>>> I think this question might have been
asked before but I didn't hear an answer to
it.
How much working together did the Google Play
services expect to have?
In particular, you have the activity recognition
and location services.
One of the examples you had was, okay, if
I'm on a bike, update more frequently.
Update less frequently if I'm not on the bike.
Will the location services automatically do
that or do we manually do that?
And other situations like that I haven't thought
of.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
Cover your bases.
Yeah, one of the advantages of Google Play
services is exactly that, is that all of these
services are backed by Google infrastructure
and Google services, and so they can work
together really, really well and start to
do clever things working together rather than
in isolation.
So it's really about taking them out of their
product silos and putting them in one place
where they can be managed and where they can
take advantage of the functionality which
each of the different components brings.
And the example from location is perfect in
that it does -- or the Fused Location Provider
already does do some clever things based on
what activity you are doing to modify those
rates.
So absolutely.
>>> Yeah, I have a question about game services.
Is it ever appropriate to use game services
for nongames?
>>Rich Hyndman: Definitely, yeah.
>>> I'm thinking of something like Four Square
badges.
>>Rich Hyndman: Something like cloud save
is very appropriate for nongames as well.
Using achievements, you could use achievements
outside of games if you wanted to.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, I don't think there's
any restrictions around having to be in one
of the games categories in order to use the
services.
It's just they're designed specifically for
that.
So the risk you have is if you -- if it almost
does what you want and you're hoping it gets
changed to be able to take into account that
edge case, if it's not in a game it's much
less likely to have that covered.
But if you find something useful, don't let
the title dissuade you from using it.
>>> Hi.
The geofences, they said it's hundred per
client -- per application per user or is it
just per application?
>>Reto Meier: Per application.
>>Rich Hyndman: Yeah.
In the back there.
>>> How does the Google Play services version,
the apps like that they work with the Google
Play services that they need?
Like do they prevent the update of the app
if, like, the Google Play services is installed
on the -- on the system does not match the
version or how does it handle version?
>>Reto Meier: So -- sorry.
>>Rich Hyndman: You're saying something like
maps?
>>> No.
The apps like suppose I'm an app and I use
Google Play services which requires a certain
API level in the Google Play services and
the guy has not updated his Google Play app.
So how does it handle versioning between the
apps.
>>Reto Meier: Right.
So what we do is we push out the new version
of Google Play services to everyone, basically
straight away.
If, for whatever reason, that update hasn't
happened, the first time an app runs which
requires the newer version, that will force
it to pull that new download down.
So it will happen I think at the time when
you install the app?
No.
When you run the app.
Yes, when you run the app for the first time
that you make that check, it will ping Google
Play and request to download the --
>>> What is the mechanism making that check?
Sorry.
Just a quick follow-up.
>>Rich Hyndman: Google Play services is Google
Play services available.
Google Play services UTIL.
It's in the slide deck.
>>> Hey, when you were talking about cloud
save, you mentioned a limitation of, like,
four buckets, each of which is 128K or something.
>>Rich Hyndman: Sure.
>>Reto Meier: Is that a strict limit and is
there a way to go beyond that?
>>Rich Hyndman: Using cloud save, it is a
strict limit and using cloud save, there isn't
a way to go beyond it, but if the Drive guys
were here they would be talking about how
you could just use the Google Drive API.
>>Reto Meier: So there are things you can
do, and because this is -- again, in this
example it's sort of optimized for games,
and we want to make sure whether people have
a Drive account or not, they can still take
advantage of persisting the state across.
So if you do want to have more data and share
is it across devices, you totally can.
The Drive team have a great API to do exactly
that, and I think they even had a session
earlier today going into a bit more detail
exactly on that.
So if that's the use case you're looking for,
that's probably a good place to look.
>>> But the two aren't going to interoperate
such that the user can see, like, this is
my game save state, and if there is something
that is larger in there, it's going to be
a totally separate thing and --
>>Rich Hyndman: They're totally separate;
right.
>>> Are you storing the geofences in the device
or in the cloud?
>>Reto Meier: On the device.
>>> On the device.
Why?
>>Reto Meier: Because it's the device that's
moving around.
In fact we want to do it the opposite way.
So the geofences we want to make it as much
a part of the device.
If we can push it into hardware, that would
be even better.
It's really about trying to make sure you
don't have to make an Internet connection
to start up the radio, which is quite costly,
to do some of these checks which we may not
need to do.
So if you're it in apps, if you need more
than 100 geofences, then that may be something
you want to do, but the idea here is to reduce
the dependency on the cloud.
>>> Hi.
Will you provide the Play services as a separate
jar file for download or what's your thoughts
on Kindle Fire?
>>Rich Hyndman: Kindle Fire is outside of
the Google ecosystem.
It doesn't have the Play Store.
We're not pushing the Play services.
We don't have our apps on it.
So the Play services is specific to the Google
devices.
>>Reto Meier: Part of that is we want to make
sure -- we have certain assumptions around
everything within the ecosystem, and we're
able to have the CTS tests to make sure the
devices have all of the features we need in
order to take advantage of most of these services.
And so that gives us the infrastructure we
need to be able to safely push this out to
everyone and know that it's just going to
work.
So we haven't -- I don't think it's a priority
to take that out and make it available as
is a separate download.
>>> Okay.
So there's no plan to push Play Store to Kindle
Fire; is that right?
>>Reto Meier: I think you probably want to
ask the Amazon guys or at least someone with
a higher pay grade than me.
>>Rich Hyndman: Yeah, absolutely.
It's a different product, different question.
>>Reto Meier: That's taking advantage of the
open nature of the Android operating system,
and they have they have done a great job.
>>Rich Hyndman: I'm sure if they want to submit
it to the CTS test rate and get approved and
go through that, they could, but it's not...
>>> A question about auth.
When will developers be able to get fresh
tokens for offline access without having (indiscernible).
>>Rich Hyndman: Without having?
>>> Webview, like client authentication.
So we need to access your data from the back-end,
from our back-end.
>>Rich Hyndman: Right, right, right.
So not going through Google Play services
but going through server --
>>> No.
>>Rich Hyndman: -- to server?
>>> No, we want to get a fresh token to access
Google data from our back-end but without
having WebView on the client.
How can we -- When will we be able to do this?
>>Reto Meier: I think it's a little beyond
either of our knowledge.
What I suggest you do is head over to the
office hours on the third floor and we'll
try to find someone who can figure out exactly
what the answer is.
>>> Okay.
>>Reto Meier: Sorry.
>>> Hi.
Actually, my question related to previous.
Do you plan to have a back-end services for
Google Play services to apply them for other
app stores, like from iStore or whatever?
>>Rich Hyndman: As usual with these tools,
we don't make announcements or talk about
roadmaps.
>>> Because it prevents using some services
when you plan to have multiple cross- -- cross-tour
application, it prevents you to use Google
service, and you want to use your own service,
if it cannot be used in a similar way in another
store.
But if you have back-end service supporting
that, then we can easily trust and go with
that.
>>Reto Meier: So you'd basically want to have
a lot of the functionality from Google Play
services made available to servers rather
than device clients; is that right?
>>> Yes.
>>Reto Meier: Again, I think it's probably
not a priority.
>>Rich Hyndman: I mean, most of those things
would appear in the Google Web APIs; right?
So things like the Places API, Maps APIs,
things like that.
It tends to be those things.
>>Reto Meier: It tends to be different ways
to access from the server.
Google Play services is all about trying to
create the best experience on the device.
So anything that you want to do client side,
there's generally a Google API for that which
you can use, it's just separate from that.
And the ones which are in play services which
don't have a back-end end component --
>>Rich Hyndman: There's far more APIs than
I can remember.
If you do go to APIs.google.com, the API console
and have a look through the APIs, there's
hundreds and hundreds of them in there, so
hopefully there's one that does exactly what
you're looking for.
Running very low on time.
Maybe the last question or maybe there's just
two more questions left.
>>> My question is about the cloud save service.
>>Rich Hyndman: Mm-hmm.
>>> When -- Is the data automatically cleared
at any points or do you have to manually clear
it?
>>Reto Meier: That's a good question.
I'm not 100 percent sure.
I think you need to manually clear it.
I know it does versioning and collisioning
and all those sorts of things to make sure
it's always using the most up-to-date version
N terms of deleting, I think you probably
need to handle that.
>>Rich Hyndman: The documents are now up at
developers.google.com/games.
So you can have a look at it there.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>> Hi.
So now that Play services is now providing
features that were traditionally considered
an operating system component, it seems like
Android is being split from an open source
project into an open source base and a closed
source OS, similar to like Darwin in OS 10.
Does this represent a change in Android philosophy
or do you plan to reconcile that later?
>>Reto Meier: I wouldn't say so.
Realistically, what we're trying to do is
offer more services for users.
So we're going to continue to build the platform
and have as many rich features as possible.
And I can tell you the platform team are passionate
about making sure that anything that we can
build to make the platform better, we should
build there.
You'll note the things we have in Google Play
services are things which have not tended
to be open source in the past or contain proprietary
data.
So things like the Fused Location Provider
and the logic that it does to be able to reconcile
between those different location providers
and use all those sensors is information that
we keep -- which we used to have in things
like Google Maps which tended to have better
location results than anyone else.
So we wanted to share that, make that available
to everyone.
And that kind of forms the basis around what
we're doing with Google Play services.
And things like you'll note that the location
services don't suddenly disappear from the
platform.
They'll still continue to be there.
So where we can do a value add by opening
up our proprietary stuff and making it available
for developers, that's kind of where we're
trying to go with it.
>>Rich Hyndman: Thank you very much, then.
We're very much out of time.
>>Reto Meier: Thank you.
[ Applause ]